okay I have an anecdote for you that's
really all it is but it's an interesting
one in a sense about the failures of our
healthcare system although I know that
this is both number one relatively minor
in the grand scheme of things and that
I'm fortunate enough to be in a position
not to be crippled financially by what
I'm about to tell you and it's also not
a serious health issue okay so here's my
medical background on this particular
story years and years ago I was having
knee pain when I would run and when I
would bike and when I would play
basketball and my doctor said it seems
like it's more than just you know you're
not 19 anymore you should go and see a
podiatrist and see what's going on could
be related to your feet so like 10 years
ago or something I went to a podiatrist
and the podiatrist said yep your knees
and ankles are not correctly aligned we
need to correct your arches with some
orthotic in soles she made me the
insoles obviously in the United States
the insoles themselves were not covered
by insurance so I bought the insoles and
paid my copay for the podiatrist and
I've had those insoles for a year and
over time for many years over time the
insoles start to flatten out just from
the weight of the person wearing them
and I was starting to have knee pain
again so I wanted to go to a podiatrist
get a new evaluation find out if I need
new insoles and also have them look at
my feet i have something called greek
feet hilariously where the second toe is
longer than the big toe and it can
sometimes scrunch that second toe and
create some weird stuff on the front of
the foot and the nail so I wanted that
looked at as well okay so I made an
appointment with my podiatrist I did all
of the right things I have insurance the
insurance is a totally normal
middle-of-the-road what's called a
silver plan meaning that my specialist
co-pays are $40 this is with a big
insurer here in Massachusetts called
Tufts health plan I don't know if people
around the country know about Tufts
health plan it's a pretty big insurer
here so I do all the right things I call
my insurance I say does my plan cover
podiatry David yes it does great which
podiatrists does my insurance cover
here's a list
great do I need a referral from my
regular doctor to see a podiatrist
no you don't you just call the
podiatrist and make an appointment
fantastic
do I need pre-authorization from you my
insurance in order to have the visit
covered no you don't David you just go
if it's someone on our list we will
cover all but the copay perfect I make
the appointment I go the doctor sees me
for 10 minutes okay 10 minutes says
David your arches are flat so you need
new insoles we don't make insoles here
here's a prescription for how the insole
should be made go to this other place
the insurance is not going to cover the
insoles the insoles are going to be
three hundred and seventy-five dollars
but your toes look fine nothing to worry
about there with your greek feet perfect
I take my prescription
I pay my $40 copay and I'm on my way two
weeks go by and I get a bill for four
hundred and fourteen dollars from the
podiatrist now how could this be I paid
my $40 copay I didn't need
pre-authorization I didn't need a
referral podiatrist covered I went to a
podiatrist covered by my plan well it
turns out that podiatry is covered and I
didn't need a referral and I didn't need
pre-authorization but the diagnosis of
flat feet is not covered and that is how
I was diagnosed and therefore I owe four
hundred and fifty four dollars for the
visit - the $40 copay or four hundred
and fourteen dollars so I say wait hold
on a second I went in for knee pain how
should I know in advance what the
diagnosis is going to be my insurance
says that's simply not our problem so
anyway I was able to speak to someone
who said what you should do is call the
doctor and ask if this is definitely
wink-wink the right diagnosis now of
course someone at Tufts health plan
can't say David let me help you commit
insurance fraud call the doctor and ask
for a different diagnosis so that we
will cover them obviously they can't do
that but I'm reading between the lines
and they say this is the system we have
I would call the doctor's office and
explain the situation so I call the
doctor's office and I explain and they
say oh we're gonna get someone to talk
to the doctor
maybe the doctor can rebuild this some
their way maybe focusing on the Greek
feet part or some other diagnosis other
than flat feet so at this point again
fortunately this is more a curiosity for
me can i altom utley get this covered I
may well end up paying 375 for the
insoles 414 for the visit plus my $40
copay right that's 829 dollars in
addition to my monthly insurance premium
of four hundred and twenty-five dollars
a month to get insoles okay in other
countries insoles are a hundred bucks
and the podiatrists themselves makes
them and it would be a fraction of the
cost so understand that part of the
inefficiency here is look at the number
of people that are involved with this
ten minute specialist visit I spoke to
one insurance person before making the
visit appointment to figure out what
isn't what isn't covered I spoke to
another insurance person after I saw the
doctor I was then checked out at the
office by someone in the billing
department to pay for my copay I then
called and spoke to someone in the
finance office for the podiatrist who
then will go back and speak to the
doctor and the care supervisor were up
to seven six people being spoken to in
seven different interactions and they
may end up rebuilding this some other
way how much of the gap between the
hundred dollars this would have cost in
other countries up maybe 150 to the
hundred to the 829 that in total I'm
going to pay how much of that nearly
seven hundred dollar difference is
related to the fact that I spoke to six
different people about billing related
issues and again I'm lucky that this
isn't serious and that I can't afford it
if I end up having no choice but to pay
829 total for this ridiculous Fiasco
I'll be okay that's not the case for a
lot of people who can't afford an
unexpected $400 expense and then of
course there's the broader question of
why would a ten minute visit to a
podiatrist even be priced at four
hundred and fifty four dollars which is
again related to all of the this BS that
is part of the system inefficiencies
bureaucracy billing coding non
payment from people who don't have
insurance and ultimately are just going
to skip out on the bill it is truly a
perverse system and I don't want to make
my story seem any more important than it
is I tell it merely as an anecdote that
I have send me your thoughts if you have
a similar story please post it in the
comments for the YouTube video for this
segment I do want to hear from you about
it